Générique
...
-Travailler en souffrant
d'une douleur vive,
ce n'est souhaitable
pour personne.
Quand cela revient chaque mois
comme les règles douloureuses,
c'est invivable.
L'Espagne
et certains employeurs en France
comme la mairie de Saint-Ouen
ont donc décidé de proposer
aux femmes une solution :
le congé menstruel.
La parole se libère peu à peu
sur ce sujet
qu'on préférait taire
jusqu'alors.
-J'espère que ça deviendra normal.
En soi,
c'est nous écouter enfin.
-Car ces douleurs de règles
sont rarement prises
au sérieux, ni par les médecins,
ni par la société en général.
-Dès qu'une femme se plaint,
on a tendance à penser
à l'exagération.
Donc c'est forcément dans sa tête
et c'est forcément hystérique.
-Alors, si le congé menstruel
est un signe positif
de changement des mentalités,
est-il dans les faits
une bonne ou une mauvaise idée ?
C'est le thème de ce nouveau numéro
de "Etat de santé".
-Bonjour à tous
et bienvenue dans "Etat de santé".
Une fois n'est pas coutume,
on va poser un débat
pour ou contre.
Pour ou contre
le congé menstruel pour les femmes,
un congé
pour les règles douloureuses ?
C'est une idée qui fait son chemin,
en Espagne très officiellement,
en France aussi.
Il y a deux employeurs
qui ont franchi le pas.
Il y a la grande chaîne
de distribution Carrefour,
qui a annoncé qu'elle allait
le faire pour ses employées,
et aussi la mairie
de Saint-Ouen.
C'est intéressant.
On va vous donner des éléments
pour vous faire votre opinion
grâce à notre invitée.
Bonjour.
Merci d'être avec nous.
En quoi les règles douloureuses
sont un handicap au travail ?
-Bonjour.
C'est un handicap au travail
parce que
c'est une douleur permanente
qui revient tous les mois,
qu'on appréhende en plus
quelques jours avant qu'elle arrive,
et qui provoque déjà
chez les toutes jeunes filles
de l'absentéisme scolaire
et qui continue après
dans leur vie professionnelle
à être handicapante,
avec parfois des femmes
qui font des malaises,
qui peuvent avoir des nausées
ou des vomissements
suite à ces douleurs,
donc c'est vraiment handicapant.
-Dans votre exercice professionnel,
vous recevez souvent des femmes
victimes de ce type de douleur.
Quel est votre parcours ?
Quelle est votre fonction ?
On regarde votre portrait.
-Perrine Goussault-Capmas
est chirurgienne
et gynécologue-obstétricienne
à l'hôpital Bicêtre AP-HP.
Lorsqu'elle n'est pas au bloc,
elle enseigne cette spécialité
est à l'université Paris-Saclay.
Engagée contre les inégalités
d'accès aux soins,
elle mène des travaux de recherche
à l'Inserm
dans le centre de recherche
en épidémiologie
et santé des populations.
Elle se penche notamment
sur la prévention,
la santé sexuelle
et sur la question du genre
dans le système de soins.
-Docteur, c'est tabou,
les règles, et en particulier,
il y a un qualificatif
qui est quand même encore
très associé aux règles,
et c'est quand même incroyable,
c'est "sale".
"Les règles, c'est sale".
Ca vient d'où ?
-C'est probablement
parce qu'il y a du sang.
Quand il y a du sang,
c'est sale, souvent.
Après, c'est un tabou sur la santé
de la femme en général.
C'est un tabou
qui est issu probablement
de cette société patriarcale
dans laquelle on vit
et où tout ce qui est
différent du modèle masculin
est tabou.
-Les règles, c'est vrai
qu'on a du mal
à en parler au travail.
-J'ai un exemple criant
de témoignage d'une femme
dont je tairai le nom
mais qui racontait que,
dans une réunion
avec le directeur général,
au moment où elle s'est levée,
il y avait
une tache de sang sur sa chaise.
Donc là, elle était pas bien,
mais l'ensemble des gens
de la réunion étaient malaisés
et tout le monde est parti
sans faire trop de commentaires.
-C'est très privé,
c'est tabou
parce que c'est aussi
l'intimité de la femme.
En tout cas, c'est vrai
que c'est un phénomène naturel.
Parfois, ces règles
sont très douloureuses.
Pourquoi ?
On regarde l'infographie.
-Bouillotte, tisane ou antidouleurs,
chacune son arme.
Mais pourquoi les règles
peuvent-elles être douloureuses ?
Ces maux semblent si banals
aux yeux de nombreuses femmes
qu'elles ne se posent pas
la question,
et les médecins eux-mêmes
n'ont pas encore trouvé
de réponse satisfaisante.
Ce qu'ils soupçonnent,
c'est le rôle joué par une hormone.
Chaque mois, l'utérus se prépare
à une éventuelle grossesse.
La muqueuse utérine s'épaissit
pour accueillir un ovule fécondé.
S'il ne l'est pas,
il ne s'implante pas.
La couche superficielle
de la muqueuse se détache alors
et est évacuée par le vagin.
Pour ce faire,
des substances libérées dans le sang
stimulent la contraction
de l'utérus.
Ce sont ces hormones,
appelées prostaglandines,
qui peuvent être à l'origine
des douleurs.
Il y aurait même
une relation directe
entre leur quantité
et la sévérité des symptômes.
Néanmoins, d'autres facteurs
pourraient expliquer
les douleurs abdominales
ressenties pendant les règles,
et même avant,
lors de la phase prémenstruelle.
Une étude de 2016
réalisée auprès de 3000 femmes
américaines
mettait ainsi en évidence
une forme d'inflammation
chez celles qui souffraient
de symptômes prémenstruels.
Depuis 2016,
la recherche a peu avancé.
A en croire le nombre d'articles
publiés sur le site PubMed en 2022,
elle s'intéresse davantage
aux dysfonctionnements érectiles
qu'aux dysménorrhées.
Les premiers touchent pourtant
moins d'1 homme sur 5,
contre 9 femmes sur 10
pour les douleurs de règles.
-Docteur,
un trouble de l'érection,
c'est un drame,
il faut tout de suite
le régler,
séance tenante.
Les règles douloureuses,
c'est pas comme ça.
Il y a un vrai contraste.
Il est intéressant de s'y arrêter.
-C'est le contraste
d'une société
qui a été mise en place
de manière très patriarcale.
Un problème qui touche l'homme,
la recherche
va s'en emparer rapidement,
alors que les problématiques
liées aux femmes,
c'est différent.
En plus,
les troubles de l'érection,
c'est le symbole de la virilité,
là où les règles, c'est sale, donc
on mettrait bien ça sous le tapis.
Le trouble de l'érection,
c'est un sujet noble,
donc il faut s'en emparer
rapidement.
-Vous pensez qu'il y a encore
des jeunes filles
qui découvrent
ce que sont les règles
sans avoir été prévenues,
sans avoir eu d'éducation à ça ?
-Malheureusement, oui.
Aujourd'hui,
on est censé avoir de l'enseignement
de l'éducation sexuelle
dès la maternelle.
A chaque âge
ses problématiques,
mais c'est censé évoluer
au fil des années.
Il est censé y avoir
trois interventions par an
dans le milieu scolaire,
qui sont insuffisamment faites.
-C'est pas dans la cellule familiale
que ça devrait se faire ?
-Il y a des milieux
où on ne parle pas de ça du tout.
-C'est là qu'il faut
intervenir.
-Mais là, on a moins de leviers
que via l'école.
Via l'école,
on a des leviers sociétaux,
alors que
dans les familles,
c'est presque de l'ingérence.
-Oui, les tabous
se transmettent.
Une femme qui a vécu ça
comme un traumatisme
pour ne pas avoir été prévenue
de ce que ça représentait
peut reproduire le schéma
avec sa propre fille.
-Tout à fait.
-Ce qui peut contribuer
à lever le tabou en général,
c'est que ce soit
plus banalisé,
qu'on puisse
en parler de façon plus naturelle
dans le milieu professionnel.
Dans cette mairie de Saint-Ouen
que je citais tout à l'heure,
où un congé menstruel
pour les règles douloureuses
va être accordé,
comment ça se passe ?
Comment ça a été conçu ?
Reportage, Marianne Cazaux.
-Parler de menstruations
dans une réunion professionnelle,
c'est pour le moins inhabituel.
Ce sera certainement plus courant
dorénavant.
-Bonjour.
-A la mairie de Saint-Ouen,
la municipalité
vient tout juste de mettre en place
un congé menstruel.
Les modalités d'application
sont encore en débat
à la direction générale
des ressources humaines.
-Il faut qu'on avance
sur la question
des critères médicaux,
pour pouvoir objectiver au plus
le traitement des situations.
Les collègues
ayant des règles douloureuses
associées à une pathologie
reconnue sur le plan médical
peuvent bénéficier
d'autorisations spéciales d'absence.
Pour les autres collègues,
on a d'autres mesures
à proposer, et il faudra voir
quelle coordination est prévue
en termes de services de santé
au travail :
est-ce que c'est la conseillère
de prévention qui intervient
ou la médecine du travail ?
-Ici, personne n'en doute :
ce sujet intime a toute sa place
dans le monde professionnel.
-54 % des agents menstrués
ont des règles
dites incapacitantes.
Ce chiffre-là, à lui seul,
il est éclairant
pour se dire
qu'on ne peut pas passer à côté.
-Il faut dire que le poids du tabou
peut être très lourd à porter.
Cette jeune femme,
qui préfère rester anonyme,
cache autant que possible
ses crises d'endométriose
au travail,
dans son entreprise
de restauration rapide.
Pour tenir le rythme,
elle prend des antidouleurs,
mais elle se sent aujourd'hui
au pied du mur.
-J'ai l'impression d'être un poids
pour l'entreprise.
C'est un peu
ce qu'on nous fait ressentir.
En fait, je peux rien faire.
Même avec les cachets,
la douleur passe pas.
Malgré les traitements, la pilule,
ça ne passe pas.
Je sais que je suis comprise
par mon gynéco,
mais j'ai pas l'impression
d'être comprise de grand monde,
ne serait-ce que mes collègues
et mon patron, justement.
Je suis totalement démunie
face à la situation.
-Son employeur pourrait
la licencier pour inaptitude.
Alors, en plus
de ses symptômes physiques,
la jeune femme s'inquiète
pour son avenir.
Une double peine
dont la mairie de Saint-Ouen
espère libérer
ses agentes municipales,
comme Thanina Ould Younes.
Elle aussi
a connu les réunions
sous antidouleurs.
Elle aussi a dû
poser des jours de congé
parce qu'elle ne pouvait
tout simplement pas se lever du lit.
Elle aussi a souffert
de ne pas être prise au sérieux.
-C'est pas des sujets
qu'on a envie d'aborder
avec tout le monde,
donc le fait que ça rentre
dans le vocabulaire commun
et dans la liste
de jours de congé possibles,
comme ça, ça libère la parole
et on passe à autre chose.
Voilà.
Je trouve ça vraiment...
J'espère vraiment que ça puisse
rentrer dans la normalité
dans le quotidien des...
En gestion des ressources humaines,
ça se fait,
c'est pas très compliqué,
et en soi,
c'est nous écouter enfin,
parce qu'on nous écoute pas
beaucoup.
-La mise en place
du congé menstruel
est pour elle
une forme de reconnaissance
de ses douleurs,
si longtemps minimisées,
et un bon moyen
de lever les tabous
qui entourent les menstruations
en général.
-Juste la honte
d'avoir tes règles...
On sort de ça, en fait.
C'est vrai que j'ai connu ça.
T'es là, t'as ton tampon
dans une main,
il y a pas de poubelle
dans les toilettes, machin...
Ce serait un truc de mec,
ça ferait longtemps
que le tampon serait biodégradable
dans les toilettes comme le PQ.
C'est vrai que c'est des trucs,
tu devrais même plus
avoir honte de ça.
Je pense même que ça va permettre
de déconstruire plein de choses,
le délire de dire :
"Qu'est-ce que t'as ?
T'es de mauvaise humeur,
"t'as tes règles ?"
"Ouais, et alors ?"
Elles rient.
-Parler plus ouvertement
des menstruations
au travail
pourrait donc profiter à toutes.
La mairie de Saint-Ouen
réfléchit aussi
à mettre des protections hygiéniques
à disposition
dans les toilettes des femmes.
-Docteur,
est-ce que vous êtes
pour la généralisation
d'un congé pour les femmes ?
-C'est difficile
d'avoir un avis tranché.
Je pense qu'il y a du bien
et du moins bien,
comme dans toute nouveauté.
Le bien, c'est d'en parler,
de lever le tabou,
d'accepter que les femmes
puissent avoir des moments
où elles sont pas aptes
à travailler.
Mon inquiétude porte
sur une possible
discrimination à l'emploi.
On voit déjà parfois
des discriminations
sur le risque de grossesse
et de congé maternité.
Si on rajoute l'idée
qu'il y aura en plus peut-être
un congé menstruel,
c'est l'inquiétude que j'ai.
Je sais pas
si elle est fondée ou pas.
-On le conçoit comment,
ce congé, d'ailleurs ?
C'est combien de jours ?
Le temps que la femme dise
qu'elle n'a plus mal ?
-C'est toute la question.
Comment fonctionne ce congé ?
Si c'est un jour par mois
mais qu'il y a
un jour de carence,
comment ça marche ?
Il faut se poser la question
en termes de mise en place.
Est-ce qu'il faut faire
le congé menstruel
ou est-ce qu'il faut donner
aux hommes et aux femmes
quelques jours par an
qu'ils peuvent prendre
quand ils veulent
et que les femmes
puissent utiliser
à ce moment-là...
-Sur la base d'un certificat
médical, néanmoins ?
-Ce certificat
oblige de trouver
un médecin qui dise pas
"c'est normal
"d'avoir mal
pendant vos règles".
Si on est face à un tel médecin,
on aura jamais droit
au congé menstruel.
-Normalement,
un congé... pour maladie,
c'est cliniquement
quand même constaté
par un médecin.
-C'est constaté par un médecin,
mais là, effectivement,
c'est rapporté.
On n'a aucun moyen
de savoir. Il n'y a pas
de test, pas d'examen
pour dire que des règles
sont douloureuses, c'est déclaratif,
mais on a un moyen
d'évaluer la répercussion
sur la vie quotidienne
en évaluant l'intensité des douleurs
ou s'il y a
des symptômes associés.
Je vous parlais de femmes
qui font des malaises,
qui ont des nausées,
des vomissements,
ça, on peut le rechercher,
mais on n'a aucun test
qui nous confirme
qu'il y des douleurs de règles.
-Oui, et puis alors...
Comment faire ?
Toutes les femmes
pourraient considérer,
même si leurs règles
ne sont pas douloureuses,
qu'elles peuvent
avoir droit à ce congé.
C'est compliqué,
la mise en place.
-Je pense qu'en France,
on a toujours cette angoisse
de ceux qui vont
l'utiliser à mal
et on ne peut pas
faire confiance aux femmes
et se dire
que celles qui n'ont pas mal
vont travailler
et celles qui ont mal
vont profiter de ce congé.
C'est une vraie question
et la question des médecins,
c'est qu'il y a aussi
la nécessité de formation
des médecins pour qu'ils soient
attentifs aux douleurs
et qu'on arrête de les banaliser.
-Votre 1re réserve,
votre principale réserve,
c'est le risque
de discrimination,
c'est-à-dire qu'effectivement,
ça a un caractère
un peu intrusif, ce congé.
Quand on a un congé maladie,
on ne dit pas pour quoi,
ça relève du secret médical,
et là,
il y a un risque,
quand même, qu'il y ait
une forme d'intrusion.
-C'est ce qui m'inquiète.
On rompt le secret médical
dans la mesure où on parle
du congé menstruel
et on rentre
dans l'intimité des femmes.
Quand, tous les mois,
une femme a son congé,
le jour où
elle ne le prend pas,
ça veut dire
qu'elle est enceinte
et que l'employeur
doit se préparer au congé
maternité ?
-Ah oui !
-On entre dans la vie privée
des femmes,
on y entre vraiment.
Après, je n'ai pas
de meilleure solution.
-On ne doit pas être discriminée
parce qu'on va être enceinte,
mais tout ça
contribue quand même,
tous ces débats qu'on a
sur la place publique,
et c'est nouveau,
contribuent quand même
à une meilleure prise en charge
de ce type de pathologies,
encore faut-il arriver
à bien les dépister correctement.
Reportage de Marianne Cazaux,
qui a rencontré des médecins
qui cherchent
à améliorer la dépistage.
-9 femmes sur 10
ont des règles douloureuses,
mais une grande majorité
d'entre elles
souffre en silence
et c'est à ces femmes
qui ne consultent pas
que François Marguerite
a décidé
de s'adresser,
mais comment les faire venir
jusqu'aux cabinets
médicaux ?
Pour y parvenir,
ce gynécologue obstétricien
s'est lancé dans une thèse
d'épidémiologie
pour mieux définir
le public ciblé.
Il a découvert
que 40 % des femmes
souffraient de douleurs menstruelles
ou dysménorrhées
modérées à sévères.
Une prévalence
largement sous-estimée.
-Ces femmes qui présentent
des symptômes douloureux,
finalement,
se voient un peu exclues
de ce dépistage
qu'on a voulu centrer
sur l'endométriose,
ce qui a été très bien,
et qui a un peu éclipsé
ce phénomène de dysménorrhées
alors qu'on a
des traitements simples
qui marchent.
-Les campagnes de prévention
sur l'endométriose
ont tout de même permis
d'éroder le mythe
des règles douloureuses,
mais il faut aller plus loin.
Quelles douleurs
doivent pousser à consulter
exactement ?
Pour le savoir, François Marguerite
compile les données
car le seul critère de l'intensité
ne suffit pas.
Les fréquences des dysménorrhées
et surtout les conséquences
sur le quotidien ont elles aussi
leur importance.
Le doctorant a ainsi mis au point
un questionnaire détaillé
pour un dépistage
dans les universités, notamment,
mais encore faut-il que les médecins
prennent ces douleurs au sérieux,
ce qui n'est pas toujours le cas.
Valérie en sait quelque chose.
Après 15 ans
d'errance diagnostique,
elle a aujourd'hui la chance
d'être suivie
par une spécialiste
de la douleur.
-Bonjour.
-Vous vouliez me voir pour quoi ?
-Delphine Lhuillery
écoute ses plaintes avec attention.
-Je viens de passer
encore une fois une nuit difficile
avec une crise très forte
qui s'est déclenchée
avec des saignements pour commencer
et puis, derrière,
tout un épisode digestif
avec le ventre très gonflé,
douloureux et dur,
des douleurs derrière
et aussi des douleurs
de type coup de poignard.
-L'algologue insiste toujours
sur un point.
-Alors, avant toute chose,
mais ça, je vous l'avais déjà dit,
votre douleur,
elle n'est pas dans la tête.
Dès qu'une femme se plaint,
on a tendance à penser
à l'exagération.
Qui dit "exagération"
dit "c'est dans sa tête",
et donc,
c'est hystérique.
On a ce rapprochement
qui a toujours été
et qui a même montré
sur certaines études
que le 1er traitement
qu'on donne à un homme
quand il vient aux urgences
pour une douleur,
c'est un antidouleur
et une femme, un anxiolytique.
Quand c'est un homme,
on le croit,
quand c'est une femme,
on la croit moins,
et c'est ça
qu'il faut déconstruire.
-D'autant plus
que cette idée reçue
retarde la prise en charge
des patientes
comme Valérie.
Les douleurs non traitées
s'installent
et deviennent chroniques.
-Quand on saigne,
c'est inflammatoire,
ça peut nécessiter
des anti-inflammatoires
et il va y avoir
cette conséquence sur les nerfs,
vous avez
une douleur névralgique
qui va se manifester
de type coup de poignard
et derrière, on va avoir
un cercle vicieux.
Ce coup de poignard, ce nerf irrité
va entraîner une perte de mobilité
de vos tissus digestifs,
pelviens, même lombaires,
et tous les tissus élastiques
qui s'arrêtent de bouger
vont se rétracter
et devenir douloureux, d'accord ?
Et quand ça s'arrête de bouger,
ça coince encore plus le nerf,
donc on a ce cercle vicieux
et puis,
tout ça va s'envenimer,
éventuellement remonter
à votre cerveau
et comme ça se passe la nuit,
on est plus anxieux,
le cerveau va finir
de faire exploser le système.
-Il existe pourtant
contre ces douleurs
des solutions,
médicamenteuses ou non,
comme l'ostéopathie
ou la sophrologie.
-C'est bon, alors ?
-Absolument.
-Merci.
-Je vous en prie.
-A bientôt.
-A très bientôt.
-En attendant une meilleure
formation des médecins,
certains préfèrent
prendre les devants
en sortant le savoir
des cabinets médicaux.
Anna Roy est sage-femme
à domicile.
Afin de viser un public
le plus large possible,
elle troque souvent
son matériel médical
pour son outil favori :
la vulgarisation scientifique.
-Bienvenue dans "Tout sur Elles".
Aujourd'hui, nous allons parler
de cet incroyable organe
qu'est l'utérus
à tous les âges de la vie,
de la puberté
jusqu'à la ménopause.
Quand les femmes,
ou même les hommes,
sont informés
de leur propre santé,
ils deviennent
les chefs de leur santé
et c'est à eux de driver
les professionnels de la santé
et pas l'inverse. C'est pas eux
qui doivent vous driver.
J'aime avoir des femmes
qui ont de la répartie,
qui disent :
"Je suis pas d'accord avec vous",
ça me dérange pas.
Je ne suis pas au-dessus d'elles.
-Ainsi, elle espère que les femmes
ne laisseront plus personne
minimiser leurs symptômes
avec en ligne de mire
un meilleur dépistage
des douleurs de règles.
-Docteure, à quel moment
conseillez-vous
aux jeunes filles et aux femmes
de consulter
quand elles ont mal ?
-Ah ben,
dès qu'elles ont mal
parce que c'est pas normal
d'avoir mal.
-Ce n'est pas normal
d'avoir mal au ventre
et quand on est face à un médecin
qui vous dit :
"C'est normal,
vous êtes une femme, il faut
"en passer par là",
c'est insupportable ?
-Ah oui,
c'est insupportable.
Il faut chercher des solutions.
On n'en a pas toujours,
mais il y a aussi un accompagnement,
ce n'est pas que donner
un antalgique, une pilule,
c'est aussi d'accompagner les femmes
dans ce parcours, de les écouter.
C'est très bien dit
dans l'émission
par la médecin algologue,
qui explique qu'elle prend en compte
cette douleur
qu'elle l'écoute et déjà ça,
le fait d'être écoutée,
c'est déjà une porte qui s'ouvre,
donc il y a vraiment
cette notion d'accompagnement.
Il n'y a pas que des médicaments,
il y a aussi des médecines
dites alternatives
et qui peuvent tout à fait
être prises en compte.
C'est vraiment ensemble qu'on va
réussir à soulager ces douleurs,
mais déjà ne serait-ce
qu'en écoutant les femmes.
-Ce qui est intéressant aussi
dans le reportage,
c'est le fait
que lorsqu'un homme
se plaint d'une douleur,
on lui donne un antalgique,
lorsque c'est une femme,
on lui donne un anxiolytique.
C'est vrai ?
C'est statistiquement établi ?
-C'est établi qu'on donne
des antalgiques plus forts
aux hommes qu'aux femmes,
toutes choses égales, par ailleurs.
Les femmes se voient plus
souvent prescrire
des antalgiques de palier 1
là où les hommes
vont se voir prescrire
des antalgiques de palier 2 ou 3.
Il a été montré qu'on prescrivait
plus facilement
des anxiolytiques aux femmes.
-C'est dans la tête ?
-Oui, l'idée, c'est ça,
c'est que c'est de l'angoisse,
mais ça a été montré
dans de nombreux domaines.
En cardiologie, par rapport
à l'infarctus du myocarde,
il a été aussi montré
qu'une femme,
on lui donne des anxiolytiques
là où on fait un ECG
chez un homme.
-En 2023,
c'est toujours le cas ?
-Il y a de plus en plus de gens
qui en parlent
pour que ça évolue, mais en 2023,
c'est toujours vrai.
-Vous avez voulu
poser une question,
comme c'est la règle ici,
à un élu
de l'Assemblée nationale,
en l'occurrence
Sandrine Rousseau,
dont on connaît
les positions féministes,
qui est députée du groupe
écologiste NUPES à Paris
et qui travaille
sur une proposition de loi
soutenue
par Sébastien Peytavie
pour instaurer un congé menstruel
en France. Vous lui demandez :
"Comment faire en sorte
"que ce ne soit pas soumis
à l'appréciation d'un médecin
"quand on sait que certains médecins
considèrent que c'est normal
"d'avoir mal
pendant ses règles ?"
Vous lui avez fait part
de votre peur
de la discrimination.
Voilà sa réponse.
-Le processus n'est pas arrêté,
mais la manière
dont ça se présenterait,
ce serait 14 jours par an
utilisables comme les femmes
le souhaitent
et je pense que c'est loin
d'être discriminant,
ça remet le corps des femmes
au sein du monde du travail.
Après, il faudra quand même
un certificat médical,
on ne peut pas accorder
des jours de congé maladie
sans certificat médical,
mais ça fera partie des négociations
de faire en sorte
qu'il n'y ait pas de discrimination
vis-à-vis des femmes
et de leurs douleurs.
-Sandrine Rousseau dit
qu'on ne peut pas se passer
de certificat médical
et ensuite, il faut trouver,
effectivement,
des dispositifs
pour qu'il n'y ait pas
de discrimination.
Ca vous va comme réponse ?
Pour l'instant,
c'est encore flou ?
-C'est encore flou.
Après, la question,
c'est cette idée qu'il faut
un certificat médical.
On l'a dit, il n'y a pas d'examen
pour les douleurs de règles,
donc je veux bien écouter les femmes
et faire un arrêt maladie
en disant qu'il leur faut
un congé menstruel,
mais on ne pourrait pas se dire
que les femmes, en autonomie,
peuvent rapporter leurs douleurs,
peut-être avec des filières
sur la médecine du travail ?
Il y a probablement des choses
à réinventer de ce côté-là,
mais faire confiance
aux femmes sur le fait
qu'elles ne vont pas dire
qu'elles ont mal si c'est faux.
-Il y a encore
des dispositifs à préciser,
peut-être
des dispositifs législatifs
à mettre en place, mais ça avance.
Ca avance très vite,
quand même.
Dans le débat public, on en parle.
-Je trouve ça très bien
qu'on en parle
parce qu'on lève les tabous
en en parlant,
mais après,
le Japon l'a mis en place
il y a très longtemps
et aujourd'hui, il est
très peu utilisé, ce congé
parce que,
si elles l'utilisent,
ça risque d'être
encore plus discriminant
et ça peut augmenter
la maltraitance au travail.
-Exactement,
donc l'outil
n'est pas forcément précieux
pour les femmes.
Il faut que tout le reste suive,
et notamment les mentalités.
-C'est ça.
-C'est ça, l'idée.
Merci beaucoup,
Perrine Goussault-Capmas,
d'avoir été avec nous.
Merci de nous avoir suivis
et à très vite sur LCP.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA
Générique
...